o lar lá o pessoal aqui quem fala é dar
que sejam muito bem vindos de mais um
velho não percebi que todas as pessoas
do mundo escrevem velho mínimo vindo e
eu vivi com ele ia assim não é feriado e
uma estrada de que um site que eu tenho
isso ou em bom estado que os sites que
tipo
espero que o site tenta é o que esqueçam
do povo falar porque só aqueles bastos
ex crianças no twitter do fã de ronaldo
neste caso vocês podem ver o vídeo sem
fontes porque sou eu que vou passar por
essa experiência e não vocês mas quando
vocês forem ver no site da taxa de
inscrição os infantis que só porque
também brutal
em primeiro lugar você se manter
conectado com o vosso conta do facebook
podem confiar à vontade porque não
abandonava a saída de informação nada
até poder que estã 15 milan não quis
milhões do haiti então certamente
assegura época e vai entrar com a minha
conta em 32 e vai embora
há certos super ansioso para voltar a
rever este site está muito bom saber que
ratton
ok estamos um cintinho escuro 11
escuridão tal uma sombra o sombra é um
homem obviamente não cair pois bem agora
olha eu também comida
ok está a entrar com uma conta do
facebook
vamos lá ver o que é que vai ser conta
antónio lamoso well well ele entrou na
minha foi que em conta esse é que está
tudo bem na tabela e está tudo dentro do
vídeo meu está brutal é possível a luz
nas fotos todas
meu deus que gaste muito muito mesmo
eu estava no meu facebook está agora é
ver a minha formação toda a europa fica
frio mas eu confio que sou a pessoa mais
velha de cinco antigos mil
o meu deus monicelli unic
olha eu toda suja a maior da europa fica
furioso e está a começar a ver que é pai
vou ter que voltar ao estágio meu eu
descobri onde eu moro
eu descobri onde é que eu foquei moro
muito fácil
ó não disse pra mim não é nosso primeiro
na uff
agora vem à minha procura se faz também
a série está muito difícil
é muito bom ver a minha cara da lei no
caso do fusível e acaba assim eis solo
vídeo foi muito pequeno mas era mesmo só
para ilustrar esta aplicação que é
brutal faça isso aos nossos amigos
quando for em casa deu só quando forem a
escola peça empresas entrarem com o
facebook e os meus forrada com a
campanha certeza absoluta esta aplicação
já é antiga e os games praia quatro a
cinco anos atrás e eu ainda funcionam
que brutal tão especial o vídeo mas foi
porque no mês eu acho que não apenas
para que vocês tenham gostado já sabem
quanto como o site favorito fique bem
até a próxima